[Music]
I don't know wanted to see your reaction
yeah I'm looking forward to it
Bing bong Bing Bing bong Bing bong Bing
Bing bong being by being by Bing Bing
Bing all right tonight welcome to
another TLC episode today we're looking
at and FISA and her relationship and oh
boy is it a good relationship built on
love trust caring for one another none
of that and FISA wants all of cortex
money and she's not even trying to hide
it and it's goddamn beautiful let's
freakin do this so we started with
George and Anfisa going shopping for a
wedding okay
when I told fisa I can't buy something
she's not really good at compromising so
to give context on this relationship he
has his own business
something marijuana related and he's
making a decent amount of money but I
know we're neared the expectations of
what and Fiza wants basically and she's
very upfront about the fact that I am
gonna be your wife for the money now
this is a three carat ovum and just so
you get an idea this ring is gonna be
about $75,000
[Music]
seventy-five thousand okay nice great
okay well there's there's ovals let's
see something like this on your hands
round diamonds are probably the most
popular instead of going what actresses
once and what's most popular why don't
you just pick a rink that you've got
them like okay what about bigger what do
you think about when that's in the five
carat range just to see now that one's a
much more square shaped cushion so the
retail on this is three hundred thousand
three hundred thousand
it should be legal to buy rinks that
expensive why I like it I like it now
that I heard the price of it now I like
it she's French we should be able to do
this for 150 for you that's a pretty
good deal maybe you should him alright
okay that's a steal you want me to buy
something outrageous that's a steal I
save hundred and fifty over under fifty
as soon as he said I even I was like
yeah sure saying three really quick I
think the ring shows how much he'll ask
me yes yes yes that's how that works
absolutely the ring and only the ring
will determine and actually not even the
ring just surprise of the ring if he
proposed to me with some cheap ring I
think I'm not gonna marry him I think
I'm not gonna do it good good for him
then please for the love of God don't
marry this woman that's too much happy
wife happy life
is there a comfortable budget that we'd
like to sort of stay yeah they said 30
every what was it 15 or 30 I'm sure
we've kind of had a budget from 35 to 45
there you go fantastic you can find
beautiful things in that range you're
going to have to sacrifice a little bit
in the color and the clarity basically
where you sacrifice is if you put like a
magnifying glass to the diamond then you
might not see a tiny little spot or not
that's the difference in these things
I know because I bought one I mean
there's one thing about being reasonable
and one thing going over budget and one
thing making me a slave for the rest of
my life like a no reaction from her
about that you want to be in crippling
debt for the rest of your life thanks to
this woman unbelievable sir cannot
believe this but I can't get her a ring
that's gonna take me 50 years to pay off
I think we need some time to think maybe
I will be able to make him get something
more expensive George and I need to have
a talk about yeah you do need to have a
talk about money Jesus Christ dig all
right let's keep watching now and if
he's a kicks George out why oh my god
this guy is it true see he's the epitome
of a symptom
so first he got kicked out of bed
already masturbator then he got kicked
out of the freakin couch and the whole
apartment man had to sleep in the garage
and you still want to marry this woman
enjoy the rest of your life I do want to
be in the same apartment with you after
our argument at the Russian restaurant
my head's been all over the place you're
basically saying they were just dating
me because I can buy you things I mean
at least she's honest
at least she's upfront about it what
goes through this man's head I cannot
understand it this is his first
girlfriend or something but I love her
so much
she's my soul mate she treats me like
and once asked me for money I love her I
need to marry her that will fix it I
need to give away half of my assets to
this woman that will fix the problem
what I don't understand it it is hard
being with somebody that thrives on
conflict like that but I really want to
have a rational conversation to find out
where things stand
because I love Anfisa why because you
got fake boobs and fake lips is that all
it takes nothing I don't want nothing I
can't fix it you can't fix stupid
she respects him in no way whatsoever
it's so clear I don't know I think he
doesn't really realize that it's hard to
be in the foreign country where I don't
know anybody except Oh which is why I
kicked him out of the flat I wanna throw
it all from the window it wouldn't
surprise me going back to Russia I mean
started packing my things good go back
hey I want the money to book the flight
back okay makes it seem like a mob deal
you got the money
yeah I got the money I'm coming with it
it'll be delivered - no problem I told
my fee sounds like one that's that's not
right my life with her and I want to
make this work compromise and visa
threatens to leave George
[Music]
the size of portions of food it's bigger
here you like yours what a positive
spirit to be around how truly uplifting
it must be to be around this person I
don't understand how guys to go through
this it must be exhausting
what are you clinging on to you don't
take care of me you don't feed me you
don't feed me he just bought you food
what the great talking about yes I knew
last night it was late and I won't talk
to you what you wanted oh my god
but you said okay I can get some stuff
done in the morning
our husbands should work and write for
his family and wife should stay at home
and take care of their house and kids
are you taking care oh my god nice
traditional valued woman even though
he's the one that doing all of it Jesus
no I'm trying my best
no you're not just saying no so you're
not ma'am I'm not gonna deal with it for
much longer
oh god what is happening
[Music]
and FISA got mad at me because I like
her I try to go see the lawyer alone
what is that dr. George I am coming back
do they have any good moments in this
relationship or is this just what he
deals with bra for the love of God break
up with this woman you need someone to
town you to break up
I'm telling you George Brit please hey
if you have a if you have a girlfriend
like this for the love of God do not
hold on to it but I remember the good
times I remember how happy we were that
one five minutes ones or in the past
brought your leg stop shipping I want to
go back to talk to a person like that
Hey
[Music]
I decided to cancel and go back to on
visa because she does acting crazy so
today I was going to talk to lawyers
about transferring my assets so I do
have a layer of protection my dude you
need to talk to lawyer please for the
love of God but I'm not even getting a
chance to do that I don't know what
would cause anybody to flip out like
this and visa refused to allow cameras
inside oh hey I kicked that again oh my
god how much can this man take I get
back to my place and all my stuff is
packed and things I wants a postnup show
agreement why does she want it wouldn't
she be better off so they got married
Oh George she got married if I want to
be married to a liar why George was
supposed to tell me everything about him
his finances but he doesn't and then he
asked me how am I not sure if I wanna
stay married to him that's exactly why
the only thing I wanted on the agreement
is about the debt and that's all I know
that's right that's the only thing you
care about because he's in depth thanks
to you and now that you're married you
will technically all the same Depp
doesn't it because you share all their
money yeah not gonna agree to anything
else it is unfair that he's trying to
put the stipulation in the past not
because I think I deserve more than 50%
no matter what but then it spends my
money so what so what
mentally twelve-year-old Jesus Christ
you yeah you deserve this you got into
this mess the signs were all there they
were all there and you kept going for
whatever reason he decided to marry this
woman he yeah
this is the worst person I just don't
think it's hair what you want well if
you don't think it's it's fair then
let's be fair let's put on the post know
that you're gonna buy me a 100 thousand
drink like a promise me she should
respect me that's more fair she makes a
good point with seeing how she's acting
towards all of this makes me realize
that I need to be careful I'm not gonna
screw now because you you want to be
happy I'm agreeing to certain things to
know this what what the hell she's hit
him to know this jeez that was so out of
nowhere that's [ __ ] up dude you should
call the cops for domestic violence at
least they got that on tape dude she's a
sociopath she's a psychopath we just
witness it so what don't smile at me
like that I'm telling you it's not me
what huh I'm telling you that it's me
what maybe let him finish his sentence
this is in saying I never seen such a
psycho couple a I'm traumatized I'm
scared but also extremely entertaining I
can have a key yes you can have a key
George was late
we were late because of you he's not
very functional I always have to wait
for him that's terrible
I can't believe he's not punctual oh
you're bad
attributes really they match up with not
being very punctual you're right it's
terrible I feel for you and please I
truly do we're going into this interview
to show that we're in love and how but
good luck that the fight is a bad
example
Zana that works yeah I guess you have to
prove that you're actually a couple yeah
that would be tough he's driving so the
drug there's pretty nerve-racking
arguing about traffic and if we're gonna
be there on time oh nice nice verbal
abuse epic even though she jokes about
it all the time on the back of my head
I'm worried what happens after she gets
it
well I'm gonna take a wild guess and
she's gonna do exactly what you said
he's such a simp if I never seen this
imp there's big it blows methods this is
what happens yeah you're equally I mean
obviously the physical abuse really put
it out out of the line but before that
it's like you're playing right into it
as well and all honestly I am in a
little day what death what he became in
depth after buying me all the things
well I got in depth for us being married
tell me oh that's kinda messed up if you
think that before they get there now it
makes sense to plug the thick heads okay
okay okay all right it's just some
accounts that I fell short on before
getting married with thank you sure now
he's nice and sexy because I was
slacking
you just haven't been honest with me I'm
telling you now you should've told me
before I've always been honest with you
and you're always lied to me true she
has been honest I'll give him that
change and if you're not ready to adopt
it I'm going to adapt what isn't it a
Demidov - what - your lies that's stupid
and irresponsible of him I do
loke she writes validity doesn't she
the green card myself I'm entitled man
it all makes sense they're a different
breed
bring your fiancee from abroad and
getting married when you're in depth
when you don't have you together you
told me you have but you two love each
other I'm sure you can overcome this
little obstacle many families are in
depth in fact you'll work this out no
problem
he'll be great yeah give me whatever
else I think I quash she's in wrong
order that's why she wanted the post nut
wasn't fair for George to wait until
after I moved here to tell me that he
wasn't as rich as he told me before
business doesn't go all what you want me
to do about how much money I have but I
spent everything I had trying to impress
her it's a pretty smart business move
right if you want to get a girlfriend
out of your lien take out a dent and buy
her all these things and what then once
you're married you share the debt half
the debts pretty good nice move for
pretty good childish oh my god he talks
like jontron its child oh my god is John
Theurer sorry John I'm sorry but you
speak the same way this childish is your
ally
so now that our future knows that I'm in
debt I'm worried that she's gonna leave
me or fill me more in debt
either way so I'm gonna be good no the
first option pick the first option first
option please please pick that one
this guy will never ever break up with
her no matter what he's so stuck does he
not have family that tells him I i watch
the first episode with him and I know he
had sisters that were like thoughtful
about him being like are you sure but
they were still supported all right
couldn't they just tell him you need
someone to tell you cuz you're not
sometimes you get stuck in your brain
and you don't make any sense
with what you're doing and that's not
good I thought he was just trying to be
cheap and I didn't know that he's really
in that he's been lying to me the entire
time and I feel like I can't trust him
anymore I mean to be fair lying about
that that's pretty messed up but yeah I
think she takes her price on this one I
gotta say Jesus all right we got more
the plot thickens further but I'm gonna
end that episode there if you enjoyed
hit the like subscribe join the members
it's epic we now have a member only tier
three minecraft server it's epic see you
guys tomorrow
Hey
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and pull
troops awaits
OOP tears coming to Nintendo's wait
and remember it has a very big TV
pre-order promotion heavy
[Music]
yeah we assetbook were sneaking around
[Music]